اهلا بكم اكد تقرير نشرته التايمز
البريطانيه ان الجيش البريطاني يمتلك ادله
ميدانيه حاسمه تثبت استعمال سلاح
في سوريا ولكن من دون تحديد الجهه
المسؤوله عن ذلك نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي
نناقشه في
محورين جديد التقرير وموضعه من الجهود
الراميه للتحقق في استخدام السلاح
الكيماوي في
سوريا ما يمكن ان يقود اليه التقرير من
تحديد للمسؤوليات وتاثير في رد الفعل
الدولي على هذا
الصعيد
يبدو الجيش البريطاني والعهده على ما سرب
في تقرير التايمز البريطانيه يبدو واثقا
من ان السلاح الكيماوي استخدم في مكان ما
في ريف دمشق معلومه تكون اذا ما ثبتت قد
قطعت نصف الطريق في التحقيق في اتهامات
متبادله بين الجيشين النظامي والحر في
سوريا باستعمال هذا النوع من الاسلحه
ليبقى نصف الطريق العالق تحديد الجهه التي
اقدمت على هذه الفعله وما يمكن ان تدفعه
من ثمن قانوني وسياسي يرقى الى خطوره
استخدام الورقه الكيماويه في بلد ملتهب
الاوضاع مثل
سوريا هي الاسعار شبيهه جدا بالسار للمره
الاولى ثمه ادله لا يرقى اليها شك حول
استخدام اسلحه كيميائيه في سوريا هذا ما
جاء في صحيفه بريطانيه استنادا الى ما
وصفته بمصادر في وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه وبحسب مصادر الصحيفه فان عمليه
بريطانيه سريه تمخضت عن اخذ عينه تراب من
داخل سوريا فحصت العينه في مركز عسكري
للبحوث الكيميائيه والبيولوجيه وكانت
الخلاصه ان نوعا من الاسلحه الكيميائيه
استخدم فعلا في سوريا وتحديدا في منطقه
قريبه من العاصمه دمشق كانت قد شهدت
مواجهات عنيفه بين المعارضه وقوات النظام
على ان ما سربته الصحيفه حتى لو صح لا
يعتبر دليلا براي خبراء ثمت فريق دولي يضم
15 خبيرا هو المكلف بقطع الشك باليقين
الفريق حاليا في قبرص في انتظار موافقه
رسميه من السلطات السوريه لبدء العمل وما
يعرقل شروعه في مهمته خلافات حول سلطات
الفريق وكيفيه تامين افراده سوريا طلبت
رسميا فريق تحقيق دوليا فيما قالت انه
هجوم باسلحه كيميائيه شنته المعارضه الشهر
الماضي انذاك وتحديدا في منطقه خان العسل
جنوبي غربي مدينه حلب قتل واصيب العشرات
بسلاح لم تحدد طبيعته المعارضه اتهمت في
حينه القوات الحكوميه بقصف المنطقه بسلاح
كيميائي فردت السلطات باتهام المعارضه
معارض النظام لا يطالبون بالتحقق من
روايتهم في خان العسل وحسب بل في مواقع
اخرى
من بينها عذ قرب دوما وهو ما ترفضه
السلطات هناك بحسب روايه المعارضه استخدمت
القوات الحكوميه السلاح الكيميائيه
ودليلهم ست جثث يحتفظون بها في مشرحه
لضحايا هذا النوع من الاسلحه ويشمل هذا
قصفا تعرضت له العتيبه في ريف دمشق اضافه
الى ما تردد من استخدام الغازات السامه في
قصف تعرضت له الخالديه في مدينه حمص ترفض
السلطات هذه الروايات وتعتبر ان حركه فريق
التحقيق الدولي تندرج تحت باب القرارات
السياديه وما تخشاه كما تقول تكرار تجربه
العراق واستخدام فريق التحقيق حصان طرواده
للتدخل
الخارجي لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من بيروت الكاتب والمحلل السياسي جوزيف
ابو فاضل من لندن ديلب هيرو الكاتب
والمحلل في الشؤون الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
والمتخصص بقضايا الشرق الاوسط وعبر الهاتف
من مدينه مرسين اللواء عدنان سلو رئيس
اركان اداره الحرب الكيماويه بالجيش
السوري سابقا والضابط
سابقا هو سابقا ضابط في ذلك وايضا الان
ضابط بالجيش السوري الحر اهلا بكم جميعا
وابدا مع السيد ديلب هيرو سيد هيرو كيف
يمكن ان نثق كيف يمكن ان نثق بهذا التسريب
في
التايمز اعتقد ان هذا سؤال مثير للا
فحسب رايي ان شيئا ما قد حدث قبل نحو
اربعه اسابيع عندما زار السيد اوباما
اسرائيل والضفه الغربيه وقال نفسه انه
بشان التاكد من ذلك لكن في سرعان بعد ذلك
نشرت صحيفه التايمز قصه مفادها ان
الاستخبارات البريطانيه الخارجيه ام اي 6
استطاعت الحصول على عينه من
التربه حيث تم استخدام مثل هذا النوع من
السلاح وتم اخذه الى المختبرات العسكريه
البريطانيه في بورتن داون للتاكد من
العينه وقالوا ان هذا ليس سلاحا
كيمياوي بل قالوا انه غاز سي اس المكثف
والذي يستخدم كعنصر مكافحه شغب وتفريق
جموع
المحتجين لكن اي كلام عن غاز عنصر غاز
اعصاب او ما ذلك يؤدي الى فقاقيع
في بشره ويؤدي الى الشعور بالاختناق
لكن
ظهور
الان هذا الكلام لكن المختبرات
العسكريه البريطانيه لا تقول ان هذا نوع
من انواع السلاح الكيمياوي ولكنه
يسمونه غاز سي اس
المكثف الامر الاخر المثير
للاهتمام وايضا بعد اسابيع تغيرت الروايه
ان هاله جابر الصحفيه
قالت
ان التقارير من
ان القذائف
التي احتوت هذه المواد جاءت من منطقه
يسيطر عليه متمردون جهاديون يعملون ضد
نظام الاسد اذا حتى الان هذه هي الحقائق
التي تحدث عنها تحدث عنها المصادر
العسكريه والمختبرات العسكريه البريطانيه
استذ جوزف ابو فاضل ما
رايك غ لم اسمع جيدا مقاله يعني وانا لا
اود كنت ان اقاطعه لم اسمع جيدا يعني
باختصار هو قال هنالك بدات الروايات تتحدث
عن ذلك ثم تغيرت هذه الروايه وشرح من وجهه
نظره كخبير عن ان هنالك نوعا من الغاز
استخد ما يؤثر على البشر بشكل سيء من
ناحيه انه يمكن اعتباره ضمن الفئه
الكيماويه ولكن باي حال اريد رايك عن
الطريقه التي سربت فيها هذه
المعلومات ا اولا يعني هناك مسؤوليه عاليه
علينا جميعا في مقاربه ما يسمى بملف
الاسلحه الكيمياويه في سوريا وهذا الملف
سيدتي الكريمه يعني دائما يلوح به عندما ت
يعني يصبح النظام في وضع جيد و وضع جيد
يعني بوضع عسكري على الارض افضل من مثلا
من الاسبوع الذي قبله وبالتالي يلوح به
دائما لانه هذا هو السبب الرئيسي وبالتالي
هذا يعني الخيار الوحيد انا برايي والذي
يسمح فيما بعد
غاره جويه او لتدخل اجنبي باعتبار انه
سوريا لديها اسلحه كيمياويه كنظام وتضرب
به المدنيين وحتى المقاتلين وهذا الامر هو
غير صحيح
وبالتالي يعني لا يمكن للرئيس بشار الاسد
بشخصيه مثله ان يستعمل هذه هذه المواد
لضرب اي اي مكان في سور سوريا لانه لا
يفيد ضرب يعني هذه الكميه الخفيفه بمكان
ما ولم يعرف من هو الضارب انا اقول الذي
ضرب هي المعارضه المسلحه والجيش السوري
يعني وفق الضغوط الروسيه
وال والايرانيه والصينيه وكل دول البريكس
وبالتالي التهديدات الاسرائيليه ومسؤوليه
المقاطعه العاتق الرئيس الاسد والشعب
ولجيش لا يمكن اخق ان يقدم على هذا العمل
ولا يريد ان يتعامل مع هذا العمل لانه
الثوره كما ت تعلمين يا دمز الغاده قد
دخلت سنتها الثالثه وكل في متاريسه وكل
يقف خلف مت راسه لا يقدم ولا يؤخر بانتظار
ما ستؤول اليه الاوضاع في ريف حمص وفي ريف
دمشق هناك هناك المعارك وهناك عمليه الوصل
بالساحل السوري اذا انا برايي هذه الاوضاع
الاسلحه الدمار الش شامل او الكيمياويه هي
تذكرنا بما حصل مع بول بريمر وجورج بوش
عندما ضرب العراق وقصف العراق ودمر العراق
وقتل مليونين الى ثلاث ملايين عراقي
وبعدها جلس على الاريكا على الصوفا وبدا
يقول انا اعتذر لم يبلغني السي اي اي
واجده مخابرات فيما بعد انهم لم يكتشفوا
اسلحه دمار شامل سيد عدنان سيد ساعود اليك
سيد جوزاف وصلت فكرتك وصلت الفكره كامله
باختصار انت تريد ان تقول بان هذا يذكر
بما حصل في العراق عندما اتهم العراق
باسلحه كيماويه وكان ذريعه لاحتلاله سييد
عدنان سلو هذا التقرير قال انه لديه ادله
تثبت استخدام اسلحه كيماويه لكنه لم يحدد
الجهه التي استخدمتها وبالتالي قد يكون
الجيش السوري الحر هو من استخدمها هل هذا
وارد باي شكل من الاشكال ان تكون هنالك
عناصر او كتيبه ما في المعارضه قد استخدمت
ال اسلحه
الكيماويه نحن اخت غاده الو تفضل الو تفضل
سييد عدنان اسمع غاده نحن في الجيش الحر
نحن في الجيش الحر لا نملك مثل هذه
الاسلحه
نهائيا هذه الاسلحه يملكها النظام ولم
تتسرب اي من هذه الاسلحه الى الجيش الحر
واستخدم هذا النظام السلاح الكيميائي على
مدينه
عذرا استخدم النظام السلاح الكيميائي على
حمص البياضه الخالديه دير بعلبه استخدم
الاسلحه الكيميائيه الزرين في 19 اذار على
العتيبي استخدم النظام على خان العسل
صاروخ سكود زراس كيميائي واد الى قتل 15
واصابه اخرين استخدم النظام المواد السامه
على عذرا واستخدم الزرين على الديابي ب 26
اذار وهذا النظام يستخدم ايضا الارين على
دوما وهناك خمس جسس متسخه شهدت في دوما
واستخدم ننظام الزين على جوبر ولم ولم
يتلقى الاعلام لم يبلغ احد عن هذا
الاستخدام في س ا في س ا واستخدم اليوم
اليوم النظام المجرم وهذا النظم وهذا
الفاجر الذي يدافع عن النظام استخدم ايضا
على الشيخ مقصود في حلب خمس شهداء و1 جريح
اليوم ان هذا النظام مجرم واستخدم هذه
الاسلحه واعراض واعراض الزرين بدات واضحه
للجميع من خلال المشاهدات تقلص بؤبؤ العين
ميوز رجفان دقات القلب سرعه دقات القلب
زبد على الفم ارتفاع درجه الحراره غثيان
تبول لا ارادي كل هذه الاعراض الم
يشاهدها هذا المجرم الذي يدافع عن
النظام يا سيد عدنان يعني استخدمت مرتين
الفاظا نتحفظ عليها هو ضيف وله رايه وله
حقه واستضفنا لكي يقول وجهه النظر الاخرى
هو لا يتهكم هو هذا رايه نحترم رايه على
اي حال النظام لا يملك هذا رايه وهو كل ما
قاله كل ما قاله هو ان هذا الحكي الان
عنما عن الكيماوي من قبل دبلوماسي غربي
رفض الكشف عن اسمه وتقرير سرب من هنا
وهناك عن البريطانيين يذكره بما حصل مع
العراق وفيها وجهه
نظر نعم اختي الفاضله ان النظام يستخدم
هذه الاسلحه كما ذكرتها لك الان طيب وهناك
اعراض بدات على
المصابين بالحرف الواحد وبالشكل كما تروها
بالمقاطع الفيديو
والتلفزيون استيد ابو فاضل اترك لك بشكل
سريع الرد ولكن لو سمحت لا نريد ان ندخل
يعني في سجال بينكما فقط حق الرد طبيعه
الحال يعني انا مش ي دعالي عليه يعني
وبالتالي يعني اصدقاء صدق اللواء يعني
الذي انشق عن الجيش
السوري ضيفك من ما بعرف من وين صدقه انه
لا يملك الجيش السوري الحر هذه المواد
فعلا بس اصدقائه ام المسؤولين اصبحوا عن
الجبهات مثل جبهه النصره ولواء الاسلام
ولواء التوحيد يملكون كل شيء بالاكيد
بالتاكيد لن يعطونه للضابط المنشق عن
ال له و يعني ولكل
الجيش ما يسمى بالجيش السوري الحر لن
يعطوهم قال عذره وعتابه اصيبت باسلحه يا
سيدتي هذه هذه يا سيدتي انا سمعته كذا مره
هذا الترداد دائما يعني يردده اللواء
اينما يكون في الاعلام هذه الامور لا يمكن
ان نحصل عليها ست غاده الا ما يصبح هناك
فريق ثالث بالامم المتحده وسوريا ترف ذلك
يا سيد جزاف بالضبط الفريق يقبع في قبرس
وان دمشق لم يكن لديها ما توفيق لما لا
تسمح له بالدخول دعنا نسال سيد هيرو دعنا
نسال سيد هيرو لانه لم يتحدث بالشكل
الكافي سيد هيرو ايضا قبل صدور هذا
التسريب عن التايمز ايضا دبلوماسي غربي في
تقارير في تقارير اخرى رفض الكشف عن اسمه
قال في تصريحات صحفيه لدينا ادله ق على
استخدام اسلحه كيماويه لما لا يعبر عن
الامور بشكل صريح وواضح حتى لا يقال ان
الغرب يتذرع او يبني مؤامره ما يسميها
النظام السوري لكي يدخل ويحتل البلاد كما
حصل في
العراق هناك نقطتان مهمتان هنا اولا وقبل
مده طويله من الزمن لم تتحد السوري ابدا
اسه كييه لكن قبل حوالي الى اشهر قالوا
انهم لن يستخدموا السلاح الكيمياوي ابدا
ضد شعبه لكن منذ ذلك الوقت هناك اكثر من
20 مكان تخزن فيه الاسلحه الكيمياويه
حوالي اربعه اماكن تنتج في هذه الاسلحه
وهناك شائعات مفادها انه تم نقل اسلحه
كيمياويه من نقطه الف الى نقطه با وقالت
الاجهزه الاستخباريه الاسرائيليه
اي السيريون نقلوها الى مناطق اكثر امانا
لكي لا تقع بايدي
المتمردين
وهكذا النقطه
الثانيه اقول وبكل بساطه انا غطيت الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه التي استمرت ثمان
سنوات الكل يعرف ان العراق استخدم الاسلحه
الكيمياويه ضد ايران
وايضا الحكومه الايرانيه عندما كان لها
ضحايا وقعوا نتيجه هذا السلاح اتوا بهم
الى لندن لعلاجهم ليراهم الجميع اذا لو ان
المتمردين يقولون ان الحكومه السوريه
تستخدم هذا السلاح لماذا لا يستطيعون هم
بانفسهم ان يخرجوا ضحاياهم الى خارج
المنطقه الى بلد ثالث محايد بامكان ان
ياخذهم الى سويسرا مثلا ليستطيع الناس
الحكم في هذه القضيه اذا انا هذه ليست
فكرتي
ولكن عند
المختبرات العسكريه البريطانيه في بورت
دان خلاصه قوله حول بعض الاعراض التي عانى
منها المصابون مثل فقاقيع في الجسم ونزيف
وما الى ذلك هذه تختلف عما ما نسمعه اذا
هم اذا
ارادوا اثبات موقفهم بدلا من اصدار هذه
التصريحات عليهم ان ياتوا باثنين وثلاثه
وع و 15 من المصابين خارج المنطقه التي
اصيبوا فيها لكي يعرضو امام العالم الى
مكان
محايد ليطلع اطباء محايدون على المساله
ويكم على هذه مساله في غايه
البساطه طيب سنعود مع بعد فاصل قصير
ونناقش بعده ما قد تؤسس له هذه الادله
المزعومه للجيش البريطاني من مراحل مقبله
في مسار التحقيق في استخدام السلاح
الكيماوي في سوريا نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الاثباتات التي توصلت اليها وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه عن استخدام السلاح
الكيماوي في سوريا السيد عدنان سلو رئيس
اركان اداره الحرب الكيماويه بالجيش
السوري سابقا كان الخبير السيد هيرو ضيفي
من لندن يقول ينبغي مثلا نقل عدد من
المصابين الى بلد محايد وهنالك يكشف عليهم
لاثبات ان سلاحا كيماويا استخدم في سوريا
هل هذا ممكن هل لديكم انتم في المعارضه
المسلحه مصابون يمكن ان يكونوا ادله دامغه
على استخدام النظام السوري لاسلحه
كيماويه اختي الكريمه كيف
يمكن كيف
يمكن لجيش حر يقاتل في الغوطه ويقاتل في
مختلف سوريا وهو عاجز عن وصول ابره اتربين
له وهو عاجز عن وصول لقمه لقمه اكل او اي
اي شيء لهذا المريض عاجز عن ان يدخل الى
مشفى ميداني ضمن الغوطه كيف لهؤلاء ان
يرتبوا انفسهم وياتو ضمن فريق معين
ويذهبوا الى سويسرا نحن عاجزون عن عن علاج
مثل هذه الحالات كيف ناخذهم الى مكان بعيد
وكيف نجمعهم
وكيف ناخذهم بالسيارات او بالقافله والجيش
النظامي يقصفها بالمواد بالسام وبالطيب
وبال وبكل انواع الاسلحه نحن عاجزون عن عن
تقديم هؤلاء المصابين الى مشافي بريطاني
او اجنبي اخرى ام سيد هيرو استمعت الى
السيد عدنان سل هو يقول لا امكانيه لنقل
هؤلاء المصابين ان كانوا احياء او متوفين
الى مكان امن وبعدها الى مختبرات يجري
الفحص عليهم للتاكد من استخدام الاسلحه
الكيماويه
كخبير هل يمكنك ان تنصح في هذا
المجال ما يمكن ان نقوله هذه حقائق بسيطه
لست انا من يصنعها نيويورك تايمز قالت ان
35 الف من انواع او او من المقاتلين
الاجانب تم تهريبهم الى س سيا لمساعده
متمردين دول خارجيه دفعت مصاريفهم لو ان
كل هذه البلدان تدفع للمتمردين والحكومه
الاردنيه على وفاق معهم والحكومه التركيه
والبريطانيون والامريكيون اليس من الممكن
ايضا والحاله هذه ان يستطيعوا اخراج هم
يقولون ان هناك عده اماكن تعرضت لهجمات
بالسلاح الكيمياوي اذا اليس من الممكن
بمساعده من كل هذه البلدان وانا اقول ان
35 ال من المقاتلين وصلوا بامكانكم ان
تعودوا الى تمس التي تقول هذا اليس من
الممكن بعد ان تمكنوا من تهريب كل هؤلاء
وبما يحتاج ذلك من مال وقدرات تنظيميه
اليس من الممكن لهم اخراج 15 او 10 ضحايا
واخذهم الى تركيا مثلا او اخذهم الى
الاردن ومن ثم يمكن اخذهم بالطائره لا
يستطيعون الذهاب مباشره الى الى سويسرا
طيب لكن انهم يقول يعطون تصريحات غير
مثبته ولا يمكن لاي طرف او اي حكومه او اي
جي ان يجب ان تكون له مصداقيه وانا
اعطيتكم امثله دقيقه عندما تم هناك هجوم
ضد الايران بالسلاح الكيمياوي جاؤوا ببعض
الضحايا والى لندن والى
باريس وايضا الاطباء راوا سيد هيرو ربما
السؤال هنا سيد هيرو الى اي حد سيد هيرو
لو سمحت لي ربما هنا السؤال الى اي حد
النيات اصلا الغربيه صافيه تجاه هذا الملف
يعني هي في النهايه ربما ما مصلحتها في
مساعده الشعب السوري ككل يعني سواء كان
نظاما ام حتى معارضه ما مصلحه هذه الدول
ان تؤكد استخدام الاسلحه ام لا ان ان لم
يكن التوقيت يناسبها هي ويناسب حساباتها
يعني التسييس هنا الى اي حد يلعب
دورا الرئيس اوباما كرر مرارا وتكرارا لو
ان نظام الاسد استخدم اسلحه كيمياويه فهذا
في حسب تعبيره سيغير قواعد اللعبه بالكامل
هذا اولا ثانيا الكل يعلم
لا تتوفر لدي وكاله استخباريه تطلعني على
هذه الامور لكنني اقرا النيويورك تايمز
وغيرها والكل يعلم ان امريكا لديها 75 الف
جندي مستعدين للتدخل لو ان اسلحه كيمياويه
يصار الى استخدامها او اذا وقعت في الايدي
الخطا واسرائيل لديها خطط بهذا الاتجاه
ايضا هم يقولون ذلك اذا لو استطاعوا اات
ان هذا السلاح قد تم استخدامه وهم لديهم
دعم من اكبر قوه عسكريه في العالم اي
الولايات المتحده
ايذا في هذه الحاله سوف تتدخل هذه القوه
لصالحهم وتعاقب نظام الاسد استاذ ابو فاضل
اختم معك بعشر ثواني فقط لما لا تحسم
الامر دمشق وتتقل هؤلاء المحققين وان لم
يكن ليس لديها ما تخفيه لما هي خائفه
ويقبع الفريق في قبرص لا يقبع الفريق في
قبرس حاولت سيدتي اول شيء مش كريمك انت
معي الليله وبالتالي ع ثواني يمكن ان
نتكلم فيها ونقول انه النظام سعى قد ما
فيه مشان يعمل لجنه يكون فيها روسيا
والصين ودول معتدله تشرف على هذا الامر
ولكن اللجنه اللجنه اللجنه لم اللجنه
محايده ليس فيها روسيا وصين منحازه لسوريا
للنظام وليس فيها دول غربيه منحازه
للمعارضه اللجنه محايده لا مش محيده خليني
اكفي لك بس من بعد امرك عم بقولوا سوريا
سوريا ت تخشى من هذا الامر انه بكره
بروحوا على ملف كيمائي تدخل فيك سوريا
بالطول وبالعرض الرئيس الامريكي على هلا
ضيفك قال كان بدي اقولها انا الرئيس
الامريكي قال انه لا يوجد النظام لم
يستعمل سلاح كيماوي هناك خوف المعارضه
والثوره ما يسمى بالثوره تاكل نفسها تاكل
ذاتها وتاكل ابنائها في سوريا المواد
الكيمياويه وغيرها وكله سو مضبوط ومؤمن
النظام هو المسؤول يا سيد جوزف على اي حال
عن تسريبها او عن السيطره على هذه الاسلحه
بكل الاوال
شك لا هناك هناك ضباط منشقين
متقاعدين منرو واشكر عدنان سلو الضابط
بالجيش السوري الحر واشكر متابعتكم الى
اللقاء باذن
الله
ا